hier suite au sommet de l'otan et au g7
et cette fois ci à l'issue de ce conseil
européen des 24 et 25 mars nous
retrouvons
le jour même du 65e anniversaire
donc du traité de rome qui nous rappelle
en ces temps troublés
la valeur de l'oeuvre de paix que nous
avons construite ensemble
alors nous étions réunis il y a deux
semaines à versailles et nous y avons
défini un agenda j'y reviendrai le
conseil d'aujourd'hui a permis d'acter
plusieurs décisions
nous avons d'abord tu es la reconduction
du président charles michel
jusque donc à la fin novembre une 24 et
je veux ici le féliciter pour cette
réélection à l'unanimité
nous avons ensuite comme vous le savez
eu l'occasion d'accueillir pour un
échange le président biden puis nous
avons également eu la présence par
visioconférence du président et link qui
s'agissant de notre réponse à
l'agression russe de l'ukraine nos
échanges on visait à confirmer les trois
volets de notre approche unie depuis le
premier jour forte pression sur le
régime russe à travers des sanctions
sans précédent soutien sans faille à
l'ukraine sur tous les plans maintien
des canaux de dialogue afin de permettre
dès que possible une issue pacifique à
ce conflit à cet égard nous avons acté
la préparation de sanctions
additionnelles il ya eu un travail de
coordination
important car tout cela se prépare si la
situation devait continuer de se
dégrader nous avons aussi coordonner le
travail en terme d'accueil des des
réfugiés je pourrais revenir si vous
avez des questions compte tenu du fait
je le rappeler hier que notre europe a
d'ores et déjà accueilli plus de trois
millions et demi de réfugiés sur son sol
ce qui est un défi d'ores et déjà
migratoire humanitaire sans précédent et
donc tout ça impose de mettre en place
les mécanismes de solidarité entre états
membres ce que nous avons veillé à faire
quant à notre soutien le cren il s'est
matérialisé par de l'aide militaire
financière humanitaire il s'incarne
aussi par cet accueil que j'évoquais et
nous avons confirmé notre volonté
coordonnées de poursuivre sans rentrer
dans la co belligérance sur les autres
sujets c'est ce sont les équilibres qui
ont été définis à versailles qui ont été
ici réitéré
deuxième élément sur lequel nous avons
avancé dans ce conseil
c'est celui de la défense et de la
sécurité de notre continent
vous en souvenez suite à ce que nous
avions lancé à la fin de l'année 2019
pour ce qui concerne l'otan ensuite sous
présidence allemande on avait lancé un
exercice stratégiques dit de boussole
stratégique qui a donné lieu à un
travail intense de nos ministes affaires
étrangères et de la défense ainsi que
service européen d'action étrangères et
du haut représentant et le conseil
européen a endossé son premier livre
brand livre blanc sous la forme d'un
plan de travail d'ici 2030 ce que nous
appelons donc cette boussole stratégique
et nous partageons tous le constat que
notre environnement proche est devenu
plus volatils et dangereux cette
boussole a été préparée largement avant
la guerre en ukraine celle ci vient
confirmer beau confirmer beaucoup d
intuition qui étaient les nôtres mais
elle renforce et skins ce qui a permis
d'ailleurs de la conforter ces dernières
semaines les grands axes de cette
boussole stratégique d'abord pour
intervenir ensemble de manière plus
efficace plus rapide et plus cohérente
sur différents théâtres parfois par
groupes d'états membres volontaires et
au fond de déployer de systématiser la
culture que nous avons en particulier
initié au sahel
deuxièmement investir collectivement
bien plus dans notre défense en
particulier dans les matériels de pointe
que nous produisons en européen c'est ce
que nous avons réitéré je vous le
rappelle dans l'agenda de versailles
avec un mandala aussi donner à la
commission ait une volonté de continuer
à avancer
renforcer nos investissements communs
dans le fond européen de défense et
l'ensemble de nos leviers et permettre
ce faisant de développer nos propres
outils capacitaires et réduire notre
dépendance y compris parfois à certains
alliés parce que nous devons avoir
construit recettes justement cette
autonomie stratégique développé donc de
nouveaux outils pour que l'europe puisse
se défendre dans les espaces
stratégiques contestées
l'espace la haute mer ou encore le cyber
et veiller à ce que le renforcement
notre défense puisse continuer à se
dérouler en coordination avec nos alliés
nos partenaires en somme notre défi
c'est de développer une culture commune
militaire c'est ensuite d'investir
davantage dans la défense pour pouvoir
faire deux choses principalement avoir
des capacités plus autonome
et réussir à bâtir justement les
innovations dont nous avons besoin pour
nos armées et ceci nous devons le faire
en gardant l'interopérabilité qui est
nécessaire au sein de l'otan on doit
continuer à fonctionner entre européens
et américains mais on doit être moins
dépendant des non européens et ceux des
filles est de taille suppose de
l'investissement mais la consolidation
parfois construction de filières
industrielles
c'est une avancée pour l'europe de la
défense qui sera complété dans quelques
semaines par l'analyse que la commission
nous livrera sur les besoins
capacitaires stratégique conformément
donc là cet agenda de versailles l'autre
sujet que nous avons longuement débattu
c'est l'énergie
il était attendu il est connu
le sujet de l'énergie nous le traitons
depuis plusieurs mois à travers notre
agenda climatique j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire pour moi l'agenda climatique est
aussi un agenda de souveraineté il est
percuté il doit être accélérée
reconsidérer à l'aune de la guerre en
ukraine parce que notre objectif
collectif nous l'avons là aussi réitéré
à versailles en en donnant un objectif
de sortie complète des fossiles liés à
la russie mais doit être de réduire
notre dépendance aux objectifs aux donc
aux sources fossiles et ça c'est le
coeur de notre agenda climatique mais à
plus court terme d' accélérer la
réorientation pour moins dépendre sur
ces fossiles de la russie et donc on a
maintenant si je puis dire deux agendas
qui viennent s'articuler le second étant
un agenda de très court terme et avec
une marche forcée qui a été décidé sur
donc le pétrole et le gaz est donc
au-delà des objectifs de 2030 et 2050 on
a cette volonté dans les toutes
prochaines années 2
pouvoir sortir de notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles russe à cet égard
notre objectif sur l'énergie lors de ce
sommet était double d'abord consolider
cette stratégie mais qui va se
construire aussi sur les conclusions des
propositions de la commission et nos
stratégies nationales que nous sommes en
train de coordonner d'ici donc à avril
mai mais c'est surtout maîtriser
notre approvisionnement et nos prix et
là l'objectif de très court terme c'est
celui-là est au fond c'est pour ça qu'il
ya eu un très long débat et c'est pour
ça qu'il ya eu si je puis dire il y
avait des oppositions de départ qui sont
bien connus parce que les intérêts
d'abord les modèles
énergétiques des différents états ne
sont pas les mêmes donc sa supposée de
la coordination et les priorités que
chacun a signé à notre stratégie
n'étaient pas les mêmes et donc nous
avons cherché à réconcilier ces deux
objectifs le premier nous assurer
d'avoir les volumes et de ne pas risquer
une crise en particulier pour l'hiver
prochain je l ai déjà dit nous n'avons
pas de risque de d'approvisionnement et
de rupture à très court terme mais il y
en a un pour l'automne hiver prochain et
donc ça ça suppose de savoir
reconstituer nos stocks et de sécuriser
à la fois sécuriser des contrats longs
diversifié auprès d'autres fournisseurs
de nouveaux contrats et reconstituer et
maximiser nos stocks puis un deuxième
objectif qu'on vit tous dans nos pays
qui est de maîtriser le prix est
d'essayer au maximum de retrouver un
prix si je regarde les six derniers mois
il a été multiplié par plus de 5 le prix
si je regarde d'ailleurs le prix en
europe par rapport aux autres espaces
géographiques il quasiment le double
donc on a aujourd'hui un problème de
prix qui est lié à quoi à notre
dépendance et à une spéculation de
marché en même temps qu'une qu'une
tension et tout notre travail a été de
concilier ces deux objectifs nous avons
à cet égard défini plusieurs instruments
ou s'est mis en situation d'abord
d'avoir une politique commune de
stockage pour l'hiver prochain ont
défini sans justement les voies et
moyens de concilier ses intérêts on a
ensuite donné mandat à la commission de
pouvoir justement utiliser
leurs instruments de régulation et de
marché en particulier des instruments de
plafonds de prix parmi plusieurs autres
mais je veux ici vous dire qu'elles sont
à mes yeux des éléments les plus
structurants que nous avons décidé ce
que nous avons décidé pour la première
fois c'est que la commission aurait
mandat pour faire de l'achat commun
c'est exactement ce qu'on a décidé
rappelez-vous pour les vaccins au moment
de la crise qu vide et c'est ça le plus
structurant aujourd'hui nous union
européenne nous achetons 75 % du gaz qui
fournit à travers les 'pipeline' si nous
savons avoir une approche beaucoup plus
groupé elle est aujourd'hui très divisée
voyez bien qu'on a une capacité bien
supérieur à fixé de prix
c'est beaucoup moins pour le lng on est
un peu moins de 20% mais sur les
'pipeline' ses massifs et donc là chaque
groupe et la capacité à définir ensemble
des contrats longs est le meilleur
instrument pour faire baisser le prix de
notre gaz et donc nous avons donné
mandat à la commission pour le faire ce
qui était une véritable nouveauté est
donc nous allons maintenant inciter nos
entreprises à pouvoir se regrouper parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de contrats divers et
variés on pourra y revenir dans les
questions il ya eu aussi des annonces
récentes de la russie qui vont conduire
d'ailleurs certains contrats sans doute
à être remis à plat ce qui est une
opportunité pour malgré tous ses
contrats existants permettre à la
commission de mettre tous nos acheteurs
et tous nos acteurs autour de la table
et d'avoir une approche commune ça c'est
un instrument très puissant pour faire
baisser le prix du gaz les discussions
que nous avons pu avoir aussi avec
d'autres producteurs européens je pense
à la norvège
me donne à penser également qu'on va
pouvoir rentrer dans une logique
maintenant de meilleure maîtrise de ce
prix ça c'est un élément puissant nous
pouvons faire parce que nous sommes
européens et que nous avons cette
capacité à peser sur le marché en
particulier du gaz fourni par gaétane le
deuxième grand élément sur lequel nous
souhaitons déboucher dans les prochaines
semaines c'est de pouvoir mieux
déconnecter le prix de l'électricité du
prix du gaz j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
le dire à plusieurs reprises pourquoi le
prix notre électricité s'est envolé
parce que quand il ya une reprise des
demandes fortes qu'on vit depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois la structure
de notre marché eq trick fait que le
prix de l'électricité
dépend de son apport marginal et au delà
d'un certain seuil cet apport marginal
et celui qui est fournie par le gaz
s'est historiquement notre formule c'est
un billet beaucoup d'autres pays
fonctionne différemment je vous renvoie
d'ailleurs très bon document fait par la
commission européenne je peux aussi vous
pouvez le voir de là où vous êtes mais
qu'est celui ci et qui vous montre très
bien jusqu'à envoyer environ 80
gigawatts on a une formule de prix qui
nous met un référentiel de 60 euros par
mégawattheure
parce que le hong anh en quelque sorte
c'est le mal la marque est clean qui se
met là mais on mobilise des énergies qui
sont très peu coûteuse
plus on monte au dessus de ce niveau de
80 plus on va aller chercher justement
d'un crémant d'énergie dont le prix de
référence et tout ça est réglementé est
beaucoup plus élevé c'est ça qui
explique aujourd'hui l'envolée et ça
objectivement ça ne correspond plus à
notre miss est ce que si je regarde la
france par exemple si je devais vous si
je devais vous donner notre mix
électrique correspond pas du tout à ça
puisque nous à près de 70% il est basé
sur du nucléaire
donc cette formule de prix aujourd'hui
fait qu'on a la double peine le gaz est
cher et parce qu'il est cher et qu'en
plus on on va chercher beaucoup
d'électricité les prix d'électricité
s'envole et donc on a donné mandat à la
commission pour revoir cette formule de
prix d'abord à très court terme mettre
en place là aussi un plafond et donc
permettre de maîtriser si ça s'envole
d'autres prix l'électricité qui est liée
au gaz mais surtout pour avoir une
formule qui est beaucoup plus lisible
est beaucoup plus stable parce qu'avec
le mécanisme qu'on a aujourd'hui quel
est le problème que nous avons le
premier les prix s'envolent le
consommateur paye cher et où le
contribuable paye cher parce que la
france par exemple a dessiné d'un
mécanisme de boucliers qu'on rembourse
maintenant mais c'est le contribuable
qui le paye par ces mécaniques
d'intervention or ce faisant certains
acteurs industriels font du profit parce
qu'ils ne produisent pas l'électricité à
ce qu en vrai surtout quand il la
produisent avec ou du nucléaire ou du
renouvelable donc vous voyez bien le
biais de marché que nous avons c'est
pourquoi certains pays d'ailleurs ont
commencé à dire qu'ils allaient
récupérer les profits qui sont faits
c'est aussi pour ça que nous nous avons
demandé par exemple quand on maîtrise le
prix d'électricité je parlais trop
technique mais le sujet est technique on
a demandé un effort à edf en ayant en
dégageant plus de volume d'électricité
au prix de référence de la reine qui est
celui du nucléaire historique et c'est
vrai que c'était un effort pour edf mais
il est légitime parce qu'à côté de ça
l'électricité produite aujourd'hui les à
un moindre coût pour l'entreprise que ce
qu'elle met sur le marché
par ailleurs on a été compensée cela par
une augmentation de capital compte tenu
des défis qui sont collectivement les
nôtres c'est encore plus vrai pour
d'autres acteurs qui ont des modèles
encore différent je ferme cette
parenthèse donc vous le voyez débat très
technique qui partait de positions très
divergentes mais à mes yeux les deux
grands instruments c'est vraiment
l'achat groupé de gaz et les
négociations avec d'autres acteurs et la
diversification et c'est la réforme du
prix de l'électricité enfin toujours
conformément à un agenda de versailles
nous avons parlé sécurité alimentaire
je l'explosé pour ceux qui étaient ici
avec moi hier l'initiative que nous
avons souhaité porter qui figurent dans
les conclusions
l'un des grands l'une des grandes
conséquences de la guerre aujourd'hui en
ukraine à côté de la crise énergétique
de la crise humanitaire que nous vivons
sur notre sol évidemment de la situation
en ukraine et de la déstabilisation
géopolitique des conséquences à venir
c'est une crise alimentaire
la conséquence est immédiate
elle sera encore accru à horizon 12 mois
et 18 mois pourquoi parce que l'ukraine
et la russie sont de très grands
producteurs de céréales en particulier
de blé historiquement et ça s'est
renforcée ces dernières années et que
non seulement il ya le problème des roms
des récoltes actuelle mais il y a
également le problème des semences qui
ne se font pas en ce moment même et qui
aurait dû se faire en ukraine ce qui
fait que le problème immédiat mais on
sait d'ores et déjà que le marché sera
très déstabilisés à horizon
12 18 mois et pour des pays pour nombre
de pays africains
proche et moyen-orient la dépendance aux
céréales et en particulier aux blés
russes et ukrainiens est immense on a 26
pays pour qui ça représente plus de 50%
de leurs approvisionnements
pour des pays comme l'érythrée c'est
100% pour des pays comme le kazakhstan
la mongolie l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan la
géorgie la somalie et les seychelles
même la turquie le congo c'est plus de
80% pour le liban c'est aussi massif
pour l'egypte ces massifs tous ces pays
là on sont d'ores et déjà confronté un
immense problème d'approvisionnement et
donc face à ça nous avons lancé cette
initiative farm pour food and
agriculture résilience mission
pourrissent pour tout de suite nous
organiser et réagir d'abord en levant en
essayant de lever toutes les barrières
de dysfonctionnement du marché pourquoi
parce que devancé effet de rareté on a
des pays qui se mettent à ne plus
respecter les règles de libre
circulation des biens et comme on
l'avait vu au moment de la crise
sanitaire empêche certains biens de
circuler pour les garder pour eux ces
barrières la faune dysfonctionné tout le
marché alimentaire soit pour alimenter
les animaux soit pour permettre la
production de denrées alimentaires pour
nous c'est exactement d'ailleurs ce que
nous sommes en train de vivre en
européen on a commencé à mettre des
dérégulations ça fait partie du plan de
résilience français à côté de ça nous
voulons aussi aller solliciter tous les
stocks qui sont faits un pays comme la
chine fait énormément de réserve est en
train de stocker beaucoup de céréales
c'est ses réserves ce stockage est
totalement contreproductif il vient
faire monter les prix et créer encore
plus d'effet de rareté est donc le
premier pilier de cette initiative en
lien avec l'organisation mondiale du
commerce conformément à l'initiative
pour la transparence que nous avions
lancée en g20 est justement de pouvoir à
très court terme éviter ces biais qui
aggrave la situation le deuxième pilier
c'est produire plus c'est assez logique
on va avoir une suite de production et
donc nous en europe et rhin en européen
de reconsidérer nos objectifs puisqu'on
avait
si dd baisse de production donc on doit
absolument les revoir pour nous mêmes et
pour être leader dans cette solidarité
et pousser tous nos partenaires qui ont
cette capacité à produire davantage
dans les conditions qui sont les nôtres
en respectant nos règles et nos
objectifs climatiques et biodiversité et
à orienter ses productions comme des
voies alternatives pour tous les pays
que j'ai évoquée est le troisième pilier
c'est d'aider des projets de
développement et financer des projets de
développement pour aller plus vite vers
l'autonomie alimentaire dans nombre de
ces pays c'est ce que nous avions lancée
avec la grande muraille verte en janvier
2021 enfin relancé avec un financement
massif qui a vocation donc comme vous le
savez à faire des projets de
reforestation et d'agro forestation dans
le dans toute la région qui va du golfe
de guinée jusqu'à la corne de l'afrique
qui sont des vrais projets justement de
production agricole et toute la
stratégie protéinique avec l'afrique que
nous avons relancé au sommet union
européenne union africaine qui est une
stratégie pour produire en afrique
et bien justement le blé le soja sert à
l'ailé et protéines végétales qui sont
nécessaires à l'alimentation
justement des de ces nations et dont
elle pour lesquelles elles sont
aujourd'hui par trop dépendantes voilà
le sujet que nous avons ici lancé mais
qui est à mes yeux très important au
delà de l'ukraine et donc de de l'agenda
de versailles sur lequel je viens de
revenir ce conseil européen a également
été l'occasion de revenir sur la
situation en bosnie-herzégovine
nous souhaitons que la crise politique
puisse trouver rapidement une issue et
sur la préparation du sommet à venir
entre l'union européenne et la chine
dans quelques jours voilà en quelques
mots le compte rendu que je souhaitais
vous faire avant de répondre à vos
questions
tout va maintenant prendre vos questions
s'il vous plaît anne saura dubois bfm tv
bonjour monsieur le président l'armée
russe a affirmé cet après midi qu'elles
allaient désormais concentrer ses
efforts sur l'est de l'ukraine est ce
que vous y voyez un recul possible de
cette armée russe peut-être un début de
désescalade et je rajoute une deuxième
question l'ambassadeur de russie a été
convoqué par le quai d'orsay ce vendredi
pour un tweet se juger je cite
inacceptable que vous avez peut-être vu
qui montre
l'europe sous forme d'un homme malade
piqué par des seringues sur lesquelles
étaient inscrits les mots russophobie
autant néonazisme covit 19 puisque vous
avez une réaction suite à ce tweet est
un message pour la diplomatie russe en
france derrière question est ce que
c'est vrai est ce que la france ait
refusé à l'otan
alors donnons le principe de ces
caricatures sur compte surtout quand
elles sont propagandistes sait que c'est
faux bond et qu'après ensuite
notre nation d'abord est
une puissance dotée qui a une arme et un
modèle d'armée complète puissante sur
lesquels nous avons massivement
réinvesti ces dernières années en
augmentant notre effort budgétaire de
près de 10 milliards d'euros par an en
plus
et qui est membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies qui
renforcent cette europe de la défense
avec des preuves tangibles et qui est un
des membres de l'alliance mais c'est une
force pour nous supplémentaires une
cohérence ensuite ces publications sont
inacceptables et le ministère des
affaires étrangères a très clairement
fait savoir cela l'ambassadeur de russie
nous croyons au dialogue nous maintenons
un dialogue respectueux il suppose du
respect de toutes parts et je pense
c'était une eu une faute elle a été
corrigée j'espère qu'elle ne se
reproduira pas je ne l'espère pas nous
l'avons exiger
ensuite
sur les annonces faites par le
commandement russe
je vais pas faire de commentaire ici
parce que notre objectif
j'ai pas le qualifier nous notre
objectif et notre obsession c'est le
cessez le feu et le cessez le feu sur la
totalité du territoire premièrement
deuxièmement ce à quoi nous devons
arriver c'est le retrait des troupes
russes et le retrait complet de tout le
territoire ces deux objectifs sont les
deux nous poursuivre en tant qu' ils ne
seront pas atteints sans relâche nous
continuerons l'action qui est la nôtre
sanctions aide à l'ukraine négociations
et j'ai une pensée évidemment toute
particulière pour les habitants de
marioupol qui vivent un des plus grands
drames
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé hier de
lancer une opération humanitaire
exceptionnelle qui
sur laquelle j'aurai l'occasion
d'échanger avec le président de poutine
dans les prochaines heures mais nous
allons en lien avec la turquie et avec
la grèce lancé une opération humanitaire
pour évacuer tout feu toutes celles et
ceux qui souhaitent quitter mario paul
on équipe a pu avoir le maire de
marioupol il y à quelques heures pour
organiser cela avec lui et nous
organiserons les choses dans les
meilleures conditions possibles mais
voyez quand cette situation hélas cette
ville de plus de quatre cent mille
habitants n'a plus aujourd'hui que 150
mille habitants qui vivent dans des
situations dramatiques et donc nous
devons absolument obtenir la cessation
des conflits là bas et en tout état de
cause nous agir d'un point de vue
humanitaire donc je peux pas dire que
c'est un début de repli ou que c'est
satisfaisant parce que là bas c'est le
drame donc voilà l'action qui va être la
nôtre sur le plan diplomatique et sur le
plan humanitaire
pascal verdu france tv
oui bonsoir monsieur le président je je
me permet de prolonger peut-être là la
question de ma de ma consoeur sur cette
manoeuvre militaire de l'état major
russe qu'il se
concentre désormais sur l'est de
l'ukraine
est ce que cette manoeuvre peut signer
selon vous le début de la partition de
l'ukraine qui est finalement un vieux
dessins des nationalistes russes
voyez je m'attache quand je réponds à
vos questions à a pensé aussi d'une part
aux ukrainiennes et ukrainiens qui nous
écoutent et qui attendent beaucoup de
l'europe aux négociations que nous avons
à conduire et donc je ne veux jamais
être dans la provocation
d'une partie prenante dix ans c'est un
début de repli défaite ce serait
contre-productif ni qualifiés ou réifier
par mes mots quelque chose qui est peut
être en train de se faire c'est trop tôt
pour le dire ceux ci indiquent très
clairement qu en tout cas une opération
menée sur tous les flancs de manière
simultanée
ces vues contrarié par la résistance
héroïque du peuple ukrainien
c'est ce que nous voyons depuis
plusieurs jours et donc il y à un choix
tactiques et opérationnels qui est fait
il correspond nous le savons a des
prétentions territoriales
qui sont connues depuis 2014 qui sont
inscrits dans les accords de minsk 1 1
et 2 maintenant je ne veux pas ici
ivoire en quelque sorte le début d'une
justification ou d'un élément
que les voies diplomatiques et les
négociations qui à un moment reviendront
quand il faudra bâtir la paix auront à
déterminer voilà donc je pense que c'est
la traduction simplement d'un choix face
aux difficultés opérationnelles
rencontrées mais je dis surtout que
notre priorité malgré tout c'est dans
cette région d'obtenir un cessez le feu
compte tenu des situations humanitaires
dramatiques que nous y connaissons
john irish reuters
bonjour merci
deux questions la première et 20 débat
intense sur le plafonnement des prix de
gaz quel genre de compromis est possible
entre le nord et le sud des allemands et
les pays bas et les pays ibériques et
deuxième question vous avez touché un
petit peu le sujet du rouble les deux
demandes du président poutine est ce que
vous pensez qu'il est ce qu'il existe un
homme comment recevez-vous cette
décision est ce que c'est acceptable ou
craignez-vous que ça ça serait une façon
de contourner les sanctions
éventuellement
sur le premier j'ai essayé de répondre
il ya une différence d'approché
pourquoi parce que les pays que vous
évoquez au nord sont plutôt des pays qui
ont beaucoup de besoins industriels une
manne agents gaz et qui sont des gros
pays de stockage et donc le ils ont ce
premier objectif
maximiser sécuriser des volumes et ils
veulent ils ont créé nier quelques
mécanismes d'intervention qui viennent
fragiliser cette capacité à reconstituer
les stocks les pays du sud ont ses
besoins mais eux ont surtout une tension
sur les prix et la consommation après il
ya des airs des situations plus
spécifique pour la péninsule ibérique
qui ont été prises en compte avec des
réponses proposées par la commission
compte tenu la de spécificité
géographique puisque la péninsule
ibérique sur le plan du gaz fonctionne
de manière quasi insulaire
sur ces sujets nous avons trouvé un
compromis par les mécanismes et le
mandat donné à la commission c'est à
dire avancer sur les deux dans le même
temps et donc continuer de faire les
appros et utiliser tous les mécanismes
d'intervention en n'excluant pas donc le
cap mais surtout par le levier que
j'évoquais l'achat commun de la
commission parce que c'est le meilleur
mécanisme pour orienter vers les prix
vers le bas et moi je pense que avoir
cet achat commun par la commission
compte tenu du fait qu'elle la
possibilité potentiellement de deux
d'agréger 75% de l'achat du gaz par
'pipeline'
plus notre capacité à discuter avec des
partenaires responsables qui savent
qu'ils sont en train de faire du sur
profits qu'ils le disent eux-mêmes je
pense à la norvège confèrent les
dernières déclarations du ministre et
changent que j'ai fait le premier
ministre hier doit nous conduire à faire
baisser par des mécanismes d'action de
marche et proportionnée le prix et si on
donne au marché la bonne indication
si on derrière on arrive à renégocier
des contrats longs alors on pourra
retirer les prix vers le bas c'est ce
qu'on doit chercher à faire donc c'est
comme ça qu'on réconcilie les deux
visions la deuxième manière de les
réconcilier c'est le cap et des
mécanismes sur le prix du gaz vendu
parce que l'on parle toujours du gaz en
gros qui est le gaz que vous vendez aux
clients et là on a décidé fini aussi des
mécanismes qui permettent de réduire la
facture au delà des choix nationaux donc
ça c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi à faire
la synthèse je crois surtout à trouver
une position qui est efficace parce
qu'on veut à la fois maîtriser les prix
pour baisser la facture de gaz pour nos
compatriotes et la facture d'électricité
mais on veut pas aussi courir de risques
d'approvisionnement sur le deuxième
sujet qui est un sujet très important on
continue le travail d'analysé je sais
vous dire une chose
tous les textes signés sont claires cet
interdit donc les acteurs européens qui
achètent du gaz et qui sont sur le sol
européen doivent le faire en europe
donc ça n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
de faire ce qui est demandé et ça n'est
pas contractuelles et je ne pense pas
que il ya une volonté aujourd'hui de
rompre ces contrats de la partie rue
sinon il faut le dire plus explicitement
mais donc nous on est pour respecter les
contrats sur ce sujet et donc qu'ils
soient libellés dans la devise que les
contrats prévoient
après l'objectif je pense de ces
annonces c'est ce que vous avez dit
chercher un mécanisme de contournement
mais il n'est pas conforme à ce qui a
été signé donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
nous l'appliquons rien il fait une
question de bénédicte tassart de airtel
monsieur le président toujours sur les
prix de l'énergie est ce que vous pouvez
assurer aux français que le prix du gaz
va baisser à quel terme et y at il un
objectif chiffré qui a été donné à la
commission alors savez c'est un marché
donc un marché il ya des vendeurs et des
acheteurs et c'est ça qui crée la
tension et ses fluctuations de prix donc
si je pouvais garantir quoi que ce soit
aux français et aux françaises et aux
français ça voudrait dire que nous
serions producteurs et que nous
régulions en totalité les choses ça
n'est pas le cas donc jamais fait de
fausses promesses ce que nous avons nous
décidé sur le gaz c'est pour ça que je
peux malgré tout pour nos compatriotes
donné cette garantie
c'est qu'on a décidé d'un bouclier nous
en franco-français d'autres nations en
europe ont fait d'autres n'ont pas fait
mais comme vous le savez d'autres les
plusieurs mois le gouvernement a pris la
décision de mettre un bouclier et donc
ils protègent les ménages et ensuite il
a étendu à certains secteurs et aux très
petites et petites entreprises cette
même protection qui fait que les
variations du prix du gaz ne sont plus
répercuter sur votre facture donc oui je
peux vous le garantir parce que nous
nous avons mis en place un mécanisme de
protection et d'intervention
simplement est-ce que ce mécanisme est
soutenable
non parce qu'il est très cher et donc
aujourd'hui si je devais résumer les
choses le gouvernement protège le
consommateur mais c'est le contribuable
qui paye et d'ailleurs toutes les
solutions sur l'énergie en pouvoir
d'achat que nous avons dans nos pays qui
font moins fit l'objet de débats
démocratiques parfaitement légitime tout
repose sur la même logique faire payer
le contribuable
à la place du consommateur pascal afin
de donner à quelqu'un à la fin à
quelqu'un qui paye puisque c'est
compensé un prix de marché
donc à court terme maurice vous garantis
qu'on va continuer parce qu'on a ce
bouclier mais pour nous protéger
vraiment qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on
doit réussir à faire baisser les prix de
marché et donc pour faire baisser les
prix de marché tout en haut en nous
protégeant d'une rupture et d'un risque
lié à la russie nous devons diversifier
nos approvisionnements trouver d'autres
fournisseurs et nous devons trouver des
mécanismes qui sont des mécanismes où on
va jouer de notre capacité à mieux
négocier parce qu'on est gros et des
mécanismes d'intervention de marché que
j'évoquais et c'est le mix qu'on a
trouvé et je pense je vous dis très
sincèrement j'ai beaucoup plaidé pour
cela c'est moins visible il ya eu moins
de débat y compris dans dans toutes les
rumeurs qui ont pu circuler autour que
le price cap mais le mécanisme le plus
fort qu'on est qu'on peut avoir c'est
l'achat conjoint c'est le plus
structurant parce que c'est celui qui
nous permet de peser et donc c'est à cet
achat conjoint ajouté à des mécanismes
de traille cap de modulation fin pardon
de plafonds de prix de modulation etc
ça c'est ce qui doit nous permettre de
faire baisser dans la durée les prix
ajouté à des négociations avec des
partenaires qui partagent nos valeurs
je parlais de la norvège je fuis le
débat qui en norvège en norvège vos
confrères interroge mes homologues en
disant est ce que vous trouvez normal de
gagner tant d'argent en vendant du gaz
et parce qu'il augmente à cause de la
guerre en russie
et donc mes homologues à juste titre
essaie de trouver une réponse à cela et
veulent trouver des rééquilibrages donc
nos intérêts sont alignés c'est une
bonne chose donc voilà comment on va
faire pour baisser le prix
on s'arrête là